so can see him stand up and walk
around so if this goes back to the fact
that his fingers are going that way so I
can't go this way
okay it also goes back to the fact that
we we don't make circles in iido we make
spirals spirals have three dimensions
not
two so I don't want to make a flat
circle
and end up pulling against his
fingers at no
point in other Dojo probably from this
angle other people do a vertical Circle
it's the same freaking thing it's not
right okay I'm now pushing against the
fingers and eventually I'm going to push
you against the thumb does it give you
mechanical leverage yes it does but
that's just power you're seeking power
and you generated more power it's just
leverage there will be somebody strong
enough you don't have enough uh leverage
advantage to out strengthen out power
okay it's not right so what we're going
to
do is curve inside his
fingers okay this
way move the quaw the quaw moves the
elbow you're inside
if you pay
attention here's my Center
Line the curve of the Spiral that I'm
making is to the left the out will
become the outside of my Center Line If
I rotate at this point you're going to
end up pulling and working against the
fingers you start go like that's a pull
I'm against the fingers and you're now
making a flat two-dimensional Circle
we don't want to do that you just start
there
here it will run it's y cycle it's now
Yin don't keep pushing it don't bring it
up it runs
out now I have to get my center
line on the other side of this axis of
rotation of the Spiral that I'm doing on
his
hand okay
you have two ways of doing
it one way is
enter there did it here's my Center Line
and is now on the other side of the grip
without the
entry it's on this
side the other way the way we tend to do
it is I start the same way and I shift
my weight onto the front leg and again
Center Line is now on the other side
okay as you in winter you keep pushing
it so what I'm doing here
is not
this it's
this
pushing
boom and I push it into the
circle and as I do the turn this is
some of you got that far as you start to
go you can't now leave the hand there
cuz now your Center Line is on the pull
side of the circle you see that and now
what you're going to do is
pull you have to keep the
hand in
front of the
circle do that side again
boom here I am I keep it on the other
side that's where you
stop
boom keep it in front right
here boom that's where you
stop if you
want his body to come over here you see
you
don't move him over
there you have to keep
turning and you can move in you have to
move them with the push on the what I
call the positive
side not the negative side of that one
Circle you're going to pull okay
likewise this is a separate mistake but
very common here amongst you is if you
pay attention my elbow
always stays inside the young line the
outer rim you have a problem when your
elbow outside you're going to always
pull this thing okay so some of you are
like okay got the first idea and now you
put your elbow outside like this you see
that this is not tinel handle there's no
position like this elbows have to stay
on the young line with my shoulders my
hands can come out of that line but not
my
elbows if you pay attention when you do
that you start to violate the spiral cuz
we're going this
way and now you take them the other way
you see that that is
now oppositional to your original spiral
that you made don't do
that boom boom
off pay attention to the the motion and
don't violate these rules of motion
there
go okay
so if if you only travel
through the width dimension you're going
to always do this
pull because your circle is going this
way
okay so it's going to be a full sooner
or later eventually you're going to pull
pull you can see the resistance on
my so you have to add I want you to add
more of the vertical plane you notice
how this grip's going down you see and
the grip the grip goes down before it
comes
in the grip goes down I'm inside the
push and the pull I'm inside it goes
down down and I'm turning it you
see not
here watch our hand watch his hand from
the
mat didn't go down I'm
pulling his hand's going to go down you
see then I turn in okay when I turn this
part see his
hand I don't leave it at this height
from the
map I'm pulling
now so if it went
down what's it got to do in a yinyang
world it's got to go up so as I get
everything I just said in the last
coaching moment as I get myself to the
other side this is where it goes
up see
no
down up into that push so you keep the
push
okay if you look at this
tactically and you pay
attention that is how you get the height
check on the leg and you're starting to
work the angle cancellation on the to l
shoulder when you go like
this it's not cutting through his
Dimensions I get some angle cancellation
but he can move his feet however he
freaking
wants so
down then it goes up and that is when
you turn you turn in the up okay try it
again okay uh again another thing that
you're going to have to change your
understanding here is at this
point tital hankle has
happened all rotation should have the
rotation that I want should have been
done and now you back up into the
neutral
space this I shouldn't have been here
and then I rotate more with that
foot so for example when here I am
everything's done
okay he is done moving and I am on the
positive side of the
circle and so now I have structural
Integrity against the centrifugal energy
okay so if he pulls that way it I'm
grounded on the on the back foot and on
on the positive side of the
circle when I continue to turn him on
the ten con
that's not going to happen so when you
feel me start to turn you not at the
beginning I'm not going to have a
grounding foot and he'll be able to pull
me see asz I'm trying to do this if for
example we could do it this experiment
don't let me move you anymore hold that
in space use all your muscle and I
try to do this
this is not
working does not make
sense so boom boom once you're here
that's it you step into the empty space
you created that's the
drill
Bo H that's it the drill's done the T
the the the ten con has finished I step
into the neutral
space done no more rotation on here you
see
that
right see this is what iido does all the
time you you go like this you see
that he doesn't want to go don't go
there's no way I can do that there's no
way you have to single point pivot you
see and then you step where you need to
go you
cannot turn on that
part so as you go on the turn is here
right there then I step into
neutral oh turn here
under power on the positive side of the
circle step into
neutral
step step in the
Neal step in the neutral then I
shouldn't see any movement in him after
that stepping in okay try
okay try to understand what I'm
showing with him trying to pull I can't
he's trying to pull or he won't rotate
anymore what I'm trying to show is this
has a given inertia that this is
mechanically inferior to so it could be
he's a bigger guy there's a bigger guy
I'm going to have a harder problem with
that it could be someone that's pulling
on me see that so I'm just representing
if you give yourself some resistance
don't don't turn your hand anymore and
you try to do that you're not going to
be able to do it
okay so the timing
is
Boom neutral now now when I'm here my
qua will come
in and out
everything we just did
turn neutral claw comes in
BO
boom this part no more movement in it
till the claw can come in
beginning of the outward
SP
boom boom neutral it's going to turn
inward
then back
outward don't make your hand make this
two-dimensional Circle you see
that you want him to come
here this is your adhesion
part not his grip
you're
here yes then look spiral you
see there start the spir don't make a
circle
make sure your hands go here hands don't
go here hands go here so you get all
that tissue this way
tissue over
here okay try
it okay we took out the x pattern
right right cuz nor
normally I'm going to come in here this
way we're not we're not we're going to
take it out
okay if you pay attention to that x
pattern
his body turns in
space his body does not go
backwards so when I go here it's not
that I have to bring him up you see how
should That Elbow go there no it's not
that I touch his head it's that I come
in now he's on my body you think cuz I I
am not trying to throw him
[Music]
backwards just because I took out the x
pattern doesn't mean I now change what
I'm doing I keep the form that I'm doing
and that form goes
here you see that it so this arm is
going to go not this way
down you see that then I want the added
benefit of the torque of my tissues so
it'll go just outside my right foot on
the
entry
down not
out that is only going to cause
injuries your performance output ceiling
is lower you can only do that on more
Cooperative lighter smaller people and
you have no internal
training that's what we want is the
internal training
try
it you wanted to turn me did you think
okay wait I got a
relax relax let me move your elbow this
is where I
am turn turn that
hip now no more movement on me move your
other foot to the side no you're turning
me leave this hand there move cool now
use your left claw to bring your elbow
in good okay there we go good and you're
trying to shove me this way
see and where's my
foot you see that you guys see that okay
and so now you're going against the back
foot whatever F right does is
this okay we don't want
that you want me over
here you see that now you push me back
again there's that foot
again you want me here you want to go up
this go up that's it and now this goes
down you
see which your leg moves there is right
there okay we'll just get there
leg here we
are go qu
till your head touches me there it is
then I go
up and then I go
down you
see go back where we were we just got
we're just here okay I bring you to me
and I move your head and I don't want to
push you back you step there it is right
there
Bo
down what makes it look like I'm
stepping or H pushing back that way it
makes it look like that is that my leg
went here you see that but if you pay
attention
here
okay and push up on
it push forward on it I'll let you get
kindo that it's going down okay down
feel how heavy it is you
see resist the temptation of
overpowering now this way only only the
choreograph is going to do that
okay inste
boom here
down that's what you're doing okay so
we're going to do it without the tank on
and I want you to actually lower your
center of gravity but you know what's
actually making the
weight what is
it no that's
physical the CH
droping boom drop that whole Chi down
okay that's what makes it feel super
heavy try it just that